hello everyone and welcome to game
number 8 of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between Viswanathan
Anand and the Magnus Carlsen now before
we check out the game we do have a photo
challenge and that previous photo
challenge wasn't the easiest one and
this one comes from a subscriber
Leandra viana Braga and probably
inspired by the previous photo challenge
he created a similar one he used photos
of a lot of players to create a photo of
one particular player so you have to
guess who that particular player is so
here it is here is his collage creation
I do hope you enjoy it and who is who is
the photo behind all of the photos so
best of luck to everyone now about this
game you've seen that first four games
were drawn then Carlsen won two games in
a row then Anand managed to break his
losing streak in game 7 now we have game
8 cousin has the white pieces and it's
not gonna be all that easy like we said
Anand still needs to win at least two
games to at least tie the match before
going into rapid and blitz so definitely
not the greatest position to be in but
you know he wasn't the world champion
for so long for nothing so this game we
have E 4 E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to b5 Crossing goes for the route
Lopez and now Anand uses the weapon
cousins been using against him all along
nice to f6 now Allen goes for the Berlin
defense and I know some of you in the
comments I've seen some of you think
that I'm doing the sound thing on
purpose that's actually not true I most
of the times I do reduce the volume
before starting to record but then
someone will send me a video a funny cat
or something or you know like now I
checked out the death footage from the
earthquake that happened in Japan and
then I'm thinking okay I'm gonna check
out that video and then I'm gonna record
and then I forget to lower the volume so
sometimes I will do it but sometimes I'm
oh I'm gonna forget about it but there's
you know and not really it doesn't
really bother me all that much so really
sorry if it bothers you so we have
castles here Crossing goes for the main
line we have Knight
first on e4 and now rook to e1 not not
the standard d4 Knight to d6 and the the
idea we've already seen in Game four
with Bishop captures D captures D
captures on e5 and 95 and then
immediately exchanging Queens and going
into the endgame so here a different
line was played rook to e1 by Carlsen we
have Knight to d6 Knight to e5 capturing
and now Bishop to e7 by Anand of course
not capturing the bishop here if you do
that then you lose the game immediately
the king is in check and the queen is
under attack either you will block in
the in roeckl capture it or you'll block
here and then of course tonight captors
queen so after 95 Bishop to e7
we have push it back to f1 tucking that
Bishop in for a for later use Knight
captures rook captures and here we have
castles and now d4 also there was there
was an interesting in between Anand and
cousin not between iron crossing between
Nakamura and Carlsen were Knight to c3
was played which which followed in 98
and night the d5 Bishop to d6 rook to e1
c6 now and Knight comes to e3 and then
with the later idea of coming to a5
after Bishop the c7 Knight a5 d5 and
after Knight to e7 check King to h8
Knight captures rook captures it was
also a nice game but white it didn't get
really all that much and cousin was
actually playing black here so Carlsen
knows that he shouldn't pursue this line
with the white pieces so instead he goes
d4 Bishop to f6 we have rook to e1 rook
to e8 and c3 here we have rook captures
on e1 and Queen captures only one and
it's very interesting this exact
position was on the board in the first
official World Chess Championship match
between Wilhelm steinitz and Johannes
Tucker torte and here in this position
and Knight to f5 was played by Tucker
torte and although Steinitz had a better
game with the white pieces in the end
Tiny's wondered and took a tour to won
that game but here unearned improves on
two tours Knight to a5 and he goes
Knight the e8 Bishop to f4
with d5 now Bishop to d3 and
g6 we have night 2d - knife - g7 Queen -
E - c6 and rook to e1 here aren't the
cross and finished developing all of his
pieces and you know it's a it's not much
but as he does control the only open
file currently on the board there's a
there's really nothing black can do to
ever gain advantage if white plays
correctly so we have brushed up to a 5
we have Bishop captures and Knight
captures and now Knight to f3 Knight
back to g7 here cross and cross since
position is very nice but the most
important thing is that he only spent 10
minutes to get the disposition so it's
it's a position that can be played and
with so much time on the clock it's very
hard that Anand will score a point in
this game Bishop to e5 we have nine
three six Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 and now Knight to e5 rook
to e8 and now Knight to g4 attacking the
Queen and here Anand goes for Queen to
d8 the more the more active Queen g5 it
doesn't really work well not only it
doesn't work it actually it would lose
the game for black but it's also very
nice it's it's it's a small inaccuracy
but it would be a disaster for black so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out how Queen how white
would punish Queen to g5 so I will give
a couple of seconds for you to decide as
usual so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are and you
know you have taken excellent advantage
of of the mistake in question and for
those of you who just won't enjoy it so
the idea is f4 and now of course you see
that you can either capture on f4 if you
capture on f4 then comes a route to f1
and then after the Queen moves doesn't
really matter where the Queen moves you
always have this nice Knight to f6 check
checking the king and winning the
exchange this rook on e 8 but after the
King moves you don't even have to
capture it immediately you can go Queen
e3 and then start an attack
two white pieces which is also nice
another idea after f4 is as of course
you don't want to capture it you know
you don't want to open the F file for
white rook
you could go Queen to h4 but then g3
comes and after Queen to d8 and then
comes Queen to e5 and again it's very
unlikely you will be able to stop this
if you move the rook to avoid and then
comes Knight h6 checkmate and if you
don't if you try something like nice the
g7 simply opening up and attack towards
a white Queen and rook then you get you
don't really have anything to do here
you have to go for Knight to f6 check
but then comes Queen captures and after
Queen captures rook captures King here
wrote back and life does have a knight
and the rock for a queen but it's it's
that's not enough compensation for the
Queen so after Knight to g4 and plays
the correct idea Queen back to the eight
we have Queen to e5 now an excellent
position for Carlson's Queen again going
for four Knight to f6 and here and goes
for the only move that that is available
to him to not lose this game he goes
Knight to g7 now this this here comes
forced Queen captures on e8 temporarily
cousin gives up his queen now the whole
night f6 business doesn't work because
here aren't can actually capture it and
if you capture the Queen then the pawns
haven't been moved repairs anyone it
would be checkmate so after an IG 7
Queen captures an e 8 Knight captures
and now rook captures an e 8 Queen
captures and Knight to f6 check checking
the King King f8 Knight captures an e 8
king captures an e 8 and now with the
material being same on the board it's
only a matter of time when the players
will decide to call this a day before
was played King to f7 h3 h6 h4 h5 and
here the players agreed to a draw and
move 33 and some of you might find this
interesting
you know Carson could have played this
g3 move to make the position
symmetrical but he decided not to date
they agreed to drew the game here I
don't know if I had this position on the
board I would really enjoy
pushing this point all the way to g3 you
know just so this would be the final
position on the board but yeah obviously
that the cousins not that kind of a guy
so yeah this was game eight of the Alan
Costin 2013 World Chess Championship
match I do hope you enjoyed it and we
still have a couple more games as you
know they decide that this championship
will be decided through the course of 12
games or until one player reaches at
least at least six and a half points so
Alan still has a nice chance still four
games to go if he manages to win two
games then they they would have playoffs
with you know blitz and rapid games and
if not then then you know that would be
it for Anand so yeah once again think
all for watching I would like to thank
Martinez play James jumper Matthew rank
Dani McCullough and followed ingenious
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too on my previous
videos here both of them will be from
this 2013 vultures championship match
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
with a couple more nice games from this
vulture Championship match and I am
taking suggestions as soon my channel
will reach 2,000 200,000 subscribers so
you know I'm definitely taking
suggestions what do you want I'm sure
I'm sure I'm gonna have a stream as
usual but you know if you have any
suggestions feel free to suggest so
thank you and I'll see you soon